Traductor: Marcelo Papetti
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Qué tienen los pobres en la cabeza?
Mucha gente se lo pregunta.
Seguro escucharon alguna vez
a alguien preguntárselo.
¿Qué tienen los pobres en la cabeza?
Se lo preguntan cuando
nos ven tener muchos hijos,
cuando nos ven ser violentos,
cuando nos ven usar zapatillas
que parecen traídas de otro planeta,
pero, sobre todas las cosas, cuando ven
que los pobres seguimos siendo pobres.
¿Por qué los pobres
no salimos de la pobreza?
¿Por qué repetimos las historias?
¿Nos gusta vivir así?
Mi nombre es Mayra Arena
y tengo casi todos los estigmas
que se puedan tener del pobre:
soy hija de madre adolescente,
no tengo padre,
somos un montón de hermanos,
ninguno tiene padre,
dejé la escuela a los 13,
fui mamá a los 14 y podría seguir,
pero antes de que se ponga
medio deprimente,
les quiero contar un descubrimiento
que hice cuando era chica
y que nunca le conté a nadie.
Lo mantuve en secreto todos estos años
y se los voy a contar hoy.
Cuando yo era chica, soy de Villa Caracol,
una de las villas más pobres
de Bahía Blanca,
donde yo crecí no había baños.
Resolvíamos ese tema como podíamos,
pero nadie de la villa tenía baño.
Por supuesto que yo conocía baños:
el baño de la escuela,
algún baño de algún lugar público,
pero nunca había ido al baño de una casa.
Una tarde, una amiguita
me invita a jugar a su casa
y, por supuesto, en la tarde de juegos,
en un momento pido pasar al baño.
Cuando paso, para mi sorpresa,
digo, "tienen dos inodoros".
"¿Por qué en una casa
tienen dos inodoros?"
Digo, "¿Es uno para los grandes
y otro para los chicos?"
"¿Es uno para las mujeres
y otro para los varones?"
Me pongo a mirarlos bien y descubro
que el segundo inodoro no tiene pozo,
sino esta chapita de desagüe,
entonces digo, "¡Ah!
Ese es el inodoro del pis".
El secreto que les quería contar
es que, durante años,
hice pis en el bidé de mi amiga
y lo que no les voy a contar
es hasta qué edad seguí creyendo
que ese era el inodoro del pis.
Ese es un secreto que morirá conmigo.
Pero volviendo al tema de qué tenemos
los pobres en la cabeza,
uno se empieza a dar cuenta
de que es pobre,
más que nada, cuando entra
en el sistema escolar.
Yo me acuerdo de que
cuando empecé el colegio
todos mis compañeritos tenían los útiles
de los dibujitos que les gustaban
y yo ahí, con mis útiles del Estado.
Me acuerdo que yo tenía
una cartuchera del Hombre Araña
y una carpeta de motos,
y mis compañeritas, en su inocencia,
venían y me decían,
"¡Ay! Esas son cosas de varón".
Y yo, que me moría de ganas
de tener algo como las otras nenas,
pero jamás lo iba a reconocer, les decía,
"¡Sí! Me encantan las cosas de varón".
Y al rato, de la nada
--o aparentemente de la nada--
a esa que me decía que mis cosas
eran de varón, la agarraba de los pelos.
La maestra no entendía nada,
era un arranque violento
aparentemente de la nada.
La realidad es que la violencia empieza
a ser una forma de vengarse de los demás
por todo eso que ellos tienen y vos no.
Pero además incorporamos,
erróneamente,
la idea de que, cuando somos violentos,
nos tienen otro respeto.
Porque cuando uno empieza
a ser violento,
te dejan de preguntar
por qué tenés las zapatillas rotas,
por qué tu mochila es tan vieja,
por qué nunca traes lo que pide la "seño",
por qué tus útiles son de varón.
Y como no tengo fotos de mis útiles,
y como casi no hay fotos
de cuando era chica,
tengo para mostrarles
mi disfraz de la época colonial,
que es un papel celofán
cortado en tiritas.
Y esta foto la pude recuperar
gracias a que, al día de hoy,
sigo siendo amiga del caballero del medio.
Y después mucha gente se pregunta
qué tenemos en la cabeza
cuando nos ven, en la juventud,
en la adolescencia,
usar unas zapatillas
que cuestan una fortuna,
como canta "Mati" Carrica,
que cantaba "de 300 pesos"
y ahora la actualizó y canta
"de 300 euros".
Estuviste muy bien ahí
porque ya de 300 pesos no existen.
Y la gente dice, "¿Por qué usan
esas zapatillas? ¿Con qué necesidad?"
Fluorescentes, gigantes,
tienen que ser "terribles llantas".
La realidad es que,
después de tantos años,
con zapatillas encontradas en la basura,
o rescatadas de algún lado,
con útiles del Estado,
con ropa heredada de un primo,
con camperas donadas de la Iglesia,
o de algún vecino,
después de tantos años de todo eso,
el día en que te podés comprar
un par de zapatillas,
no te alcanza con poder comprártelas,
se tiene que notar que te las compraste.
Y que sentimos que así,
van a pensar que no somos tan pobres.
Nos sentimos mucho menos pobres
con esas zapatillas.
Sentimos que así
nadie se va a dar cuenta ya
de todos los años que pasamos
con zapatillas encontradas en la basura.
Pero además de que usamos
estas zapatillas traídas de otro planeta,
y de que somos violentos porque creemos
que así nos van a respetar,
o que así nos vengamos
de todo lo que tienen los otros,
además somos vagos.
No sé si alguna vez tuvieron
un albañil "laburando" en su casa,
pero yo les puedo asegurar
que el tipo el lunes no aparece.
La gente dice, "¿Por qué?
¿Por qué no trabajan?"
¿No nos gusta trabajar?
¿Vivimos de planes, como muchos dicen?
Antes no había planes y éramos igual.
La realidad es que esto viene
marcado desde la infancia
y hay una diferencia muy grande,
con la que yo insisto siempre,
y es que no es lo mismo la pobreza
estructural que la pobreza esporádica.
La pobreza esporádica la ha conocido
la mayoría de los argentinos,
es cuando el jefe o la jefa de familia
se quedó sin trabajo,
se conocieron los fideos blancos,
se empezó a caminar
en vez de andar en auto
y se sobrevivió;
pero siempre tuvieron a sus padres
trabajando todos los días,
o saliendo a buscar "laburo"
todos los días
y, sobre todas las cosas,
mandándolos a la escuela todos los días.
Los que crecemos
en la pobreza estructural,
los que crecemos
en los márgenes de la sociedad,
vamos a la escuela cuando podemos,
cuando se puede.
Jamás nadie nos enseña que hay que cumplir
con algo de lunes a viernes.
Jamás adquirimos la costumbre
de madrugar todos los días.
Y, como Uds. saben,
todo lo que uno no aprende de chico
es muy difícil incorporarlo de grande.
Y después ocurre
que los empleadores te dicen,
"Contrato un 'pibe'. No viene nunca.
Siempre pasa algo, pierde el colectivo".
Y uno dice, "¿Por qué?
¿Por qué no vamos a trabajar?"
La realidad es que no tenemos
incorporado el ritmo laboral.
Pero cuando más se pregunta la gente
qué tenemos en la cabeza los pobres,
es cuando nos ven tener muchos hijos.
La gente se desespera cuando ve
que los pobres tenemos hijos.
Y yo, después de contarles esto,
que somos violentos
porque creemos, erróneamente,
que así nos van a respetar
y que usamos estas zapatillas
porque creemos que así
nos vamos a ver menos pobres,
y que somos vagos porque no tenemos
incorporado el ritmo laboral,
me gustaría tener algo más anecdótico
o más entretenido para explicarles
por qué tenemos hijos,
pero es mucho más simple.
Los pobres tenemos hijos
porque es lo único que podemos tener.
Y tenemos muchos
porque encontramos en cada hijo
una razón para levantarnos todos los días
a pesar de nuestra pobreza.
Y Uds. dirán, "¿Por qué esta 'piba',
que creció así y que cuenta que vivió así,
hoy está parada acá contándonos esto?"
Y es una pregunta legítima.
La realidad es que...
una familia que te invita
a su casa a jugar
te enseña mucho más que a usar el baño.
Te enseña que la vida
puede ser de otra manera,
que te la podés ganar de otra manera
y que la podés vivir de otra manera.
Pero no solamente yo aprendí de ellos eso,
ellos también lo aprendieron
de mí y de mi familia.
Y yo no sé si Uds. son el amigo
que presta el baño
o el amigo que se sorprende
del baño del otro amigo,
pero está bueno juntarse
con gente con un baño diferente.
Y no solo por el hecho de que te enseña
que hay otras maneras de ver la vida,
sino por lo más importante y lo que a mí
me llevó muchísimos años entender,
porque yo estuve muchos años
muy enojada por los útiles,
los disfraces, las zapatillas,
pero entendí que nadie elige
con qué baño nacer.
Yo sé que hemos avanzado mucho
los argentinos como sociedad, muchísimo.
Sé que antes era un crimen ser homosexual
y hoy, en cambio, nos parece un escándalo
que se ataque a alguien por su sexualidad.
Antes era un pecado ser mujer
y pretender hacer algo más
que no fueran las tareas del hogar
y hoy, en cambio, es un escándalo
que nos quieran asignar una tarea
por el hecho de ser mujeres.
Y yo celebro que nos escandalicemos
ante esas cosas.
Pero hay algo ante
lo que no nos escandalizamos.
No nos escandalizamos con la pobreza.
Vamos por calle y vemos un tipo
durmiendo a la intemperie
y no nos escandaliza.
Vamos por calle y vemos un "pibito"
pidiendo o vendiendo,
en vez de estar jugando,
y no nos escandaliza.
Yo no vine acá a dar
esta charla para pedirles
que se escandalicen ahora todo el tiempo
cada vez que ven un pobre,
ni que corran a invitarlo
a pasar a su baño,
lo que vine a decirles
es esta idea que tengo
de que es una injusticia que a los pobres
se nos condene por no ser educados,
pero nadie se pregunta jamás
si recibimos educación.
Y a los pobres se nos condena
por no ser respetuosos,
pero nadie se pregunta
si alguna vez recibimos respeto.
Y, si me pongo un poco más
sentimental y abstracta,
a los pobres se nos juzga mucho
por ser fríos, por no ser amorosos,
pero nadie se pregunta nunca
si alguna vez recibimos amor.
A mí me gustaría...
decirles...
Yo sé que cuesta mucho entender...
cómo somos y qué tenemos en la cabeza
y sé que es muy difícil comprender
y ponerse en los zapatos del otro,
y sé que muchas veces se enojan
cuando nos ven ser como somos;
pero ahora, cuando salgan de acá,
cada vez que se crucen a un "villero",
a un pobre, a un marginal,
porque se van a cruzar,
porque somos un montón,
porque estamos por todos lados
y porque no somos invisibles
como muchos dicen,
pero cuando se lo crucen,
antes de enojarse,
antes de preguntarse qué tienen
estos tipos en la cabeza,
me gustaría que piensen
si se hubieran enojado con una nena
que les hizo pis en el bidé
porque nunca había visto un baño.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)